let's talk a little bit about voter
suppression in Wisconsin in 2016
300,000 registered voters are about 9%
of the electorate didn't have voter IDs
that adhered to Wisconsin's pretty
strict voter ID laws we now have a new
study by Priorities USA and it argues
that Wisconsin's voter ID laws reduced
voter turnout by two hundred thousand
votes and disproportionately affected
black voters and Democrats two hundred
thousand people not voting because of
voter ID laws Donald Trump won Wisconsin
by only twenty two thousand seven
hundred and forty eight votes simple
math that most of us can do suggests
that the new voter ID laws pushed by
Republicans including in Wisconsin may
have given Donald Trump Wisconsin in the
2016 election but the study contrasted
voter turnout in states with similarly
strict voter ID laws to states without
such laws we have a chart that we can
put up for you related to this and as
you can see the states that made no
changes to their voter ID requirements
saw turnout go up from 2012 to 2016
states that changed to go to less strict
voter ID laws also saw an increase in
turnout from 2012 to 2016 and as you can
see at the bottom line states that
change their voter ID laws to stricter
laws saw a nearly two percent decline in
voter turnout that's something that
Republicans like because Republicans do
better when voter turnout is lower let's
now go Pat to our next graph throughout
the entire country the study estimates
that strict voter ID laws suppress about
four hundred thousand votes again
disproportionately affecting black
people and the study compared numbers
between Wisconsin and Minnesota a state
with similar demographics to Wisconsin
but no strict voter ID laws and if
you're looking at this graphic the Green
Line is black Minnesota voters over
recent elections and as you can see
turnout just
ever so slightly lower in 2016 than in
2012 and if you look at the yellow line
you will see that black Wisconsin voters
had significantly voter turnout from
2012 to 2016 this isn't the only study
that says this is consistent with a GAO
study from 2014 which showed that yes
strict voter ID laws affected the 2012
election enough to change election
results suppressing young and minority
voters of course this is the case this
is what these laws are made to do this
is what Republicans want this helps
Republicans win remember this video
damming video from Pennsylvania State
Representative Mike tar-zhay
in 2012 voter ID which is going to allow
Governor Romney to win the state of
Pennsylvania done right not a secret
they've been honest about this for a
while lower turnout is good for
Republicans or just for the more
conservative candidate that's running
yeah it's hard to believe that they
support voter IDs just out of principle
and not because they know it'll give
them a benefit in the upcoming elections
31 states ask for some form of ID at the
ballot 15 ask for photo ID and bills
that would intensify voter ID laws have
been introduced in 19 states so far this
year Iowa and Arkansas have already
passed laws like that in 2017 but again
solutions to problems that don't exist
voter fraud the way Republicans
described is not a problem there were
something like you were saying Pat four
instances of in-person voter fraud
during the 2016 election and yeah three
of them were Republican voters
I mean it's so statistically
insignificant and those four cases fall
far short of the 3 5 million people that
Trump claims voted illegally in that
election right yeah as if we still are
going to pretend that there was even a
chance that that was a real thing we
should also be voting on weekends or at
least have an election day be a federal
holiday I've mentioned that before but
you've got to make the IDS easier to get
people say hey the voter IDs are free
that's not really true very often you
need documents in order to get the
voting ID that you have to pay for
copies of very often people have to
travel and often which has costs to the
place where you can get one of those
IDs and also many people who work hourly
jobs during business hours have to take
time off from that job in order to go
and get the ID and that's money that
they are going to lose and not only that
it's they could also get fired and a lot
of hourly jobs you can't just say I'm
going to go get a voter ID give me time
off there are repercussions for that
yeah those voter IDs have to be
completely free because otherwise it
violates the 24th amendment which and
the poll tax if a Republican says how
hard is it to get an ID you're just
trying to get more minorities to vote
that's also not really a criticism like
are you arguing it's bad for more people
to vote are you saying it we would be
better off if our representative
democracy was only representative of a
smaller portion of the people in the
country Republicans know that they can't
continue to win on policy alone and they
have to keep voters as white as possible
and that's what's behind a lot of these
proposals and there's a lot of
discussions about this on our reddit
discussion forum which I encourage you
to check out david pakman.com slash re d
di t today's program is made possible in
part by taga dabbe they are the hosting
specialists offering all sorts of
hosting packages including cloud server
solutions virtual private server
dedicated servers colocation options and
their customer service is really sort of
their Forte there are so many hosting
companies around and they at taga dab
really take pride in the customer
service and expert advice that they
offer if you look them up on Trustpilot
they are rated at a nine point seven out
of ten that is an excellent rating on
Trustpilot and they are offering the
David Pakman show audience a 10 British
Pound credit on a cloud server solution
for new customers you can learn more
about this and sign up at signup Hagia
dab comm slash TDP s that is signup dot
ta ga da b.com forward slash TDP s by
supporting our sponsors you are also
supporting our program check it out
signup tag adapt com forward slash TDP s